evening members just before the meeting
I need to read out the emergency
evacuation announcement
can hear this on hello hello long get
better right always helps should we be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the building by the
nearest available exit to the chamber
our assembly point will be in a public
car park at the side of the Civic suite
please don't do please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please don't please do not return to the
building until give a permission to do
so by council staff and please note that
this meeting will be audio recorded
thank you
[Music]
members please be upstanding to receive
the chairman the Chairman's chaplain and
the managing director
good evening member sir please remain
standing forward sir just bow our heads
for a moment
generous and loving God each of us come
here tonight father we come with our own
concerns and where is those things that
we have left behind that we might be
here tonight yet Lord we leave them with
you
father helpers to simply leave those
concerns and anxieties that father we
might focus on the affairs of tonight we
thank you that you've given us those
positions of responsibility in our
communities give us clarity of thought
wisdom and direction by your Holy Spirit
and all the decisions that would be
taken on important matters of budget
this evening so gracious Lord we offer
ourselves skills those things that we
come with and we also offer those who we
are concerned for to you so be with us
in all that deliberations this evening
we pray amen
this is yeah
Thank You Emily we have apologies for
absence procedure in the office
counselor Hulk wait counselor mrs. Mason
counselor mr. Mason counselor Mountain
counselor item counts for sparing and
counselor Carter are there any others
yes I did say that better I'm not very
close to it good okay
no no others good thank you very much
and now receive any declarations of
interest no in that case we move
immediately to item three on the agenda
a few words Thank You chair and just
before I hand over to the leader to
introduce the report and I just wanted
to point make a point of clarification
in terms of the appendices which were
two of those were reissued after the
original papers were published so
appendix two fees and charges was
amended in terms of the licensing fees
and appendix three capital and treasury
management strategy was also some of the
tables in that were amended following
review committee last week so those
appendices were reissued and have been
published on the website as well so it's
just a point point of clarification and
so I hand over to their leader
[Music]
Thank You chairman
just to say chairman we introduced this
budget for the following year and I
think I'm very proud of the way that the
finances of the council have been
managed in the past year I think this
budget introduces some new aspects of
we're actually spending a bit of money
rather than having to make savings all
the time and that's because of the way
that it's been managed in the past I
must say that I'm very impressed by our
offices and the way that they've handled
the budget and I think I think people
realize how much work goes into this
behind the scenes both with officers and
members so I pay tribute to all of them
and just to say I think it's a really
good budget and I would recommend make
the recommendations accordingly that are
on the papers thank you thank you
Kenneth Smith third second Chancellor
cut more it also like to commend Noemi
Lucas and her team for on the work
that's been done on tonight's papers
she'll shortly take you through the
hours of hard work and diligence that
have resulted in the balanced budget for
1920 that's put to us tonight but before
she does I'd like to direct members to
page 3 point 17 a small line in print
but with a very significant meaning
environmental services six five seven
eight oh one is the bigger I'm talking
about
the recent years key message has been
coming from all levels of government and
it's been austerity RDC has been no
different and it's had to make some hard
decisions about its budgets the council
still has to make day-to-day budgets run
and that's been very hard over the last
few years they've been a good number of
new homes and families coming into the
district new homes built new families
coming into the district and for that
the council has received a bonus a new
homes bonus now with careful managing of
the finances it's time to give some of
that bonus back within the challenges of
our budget we've worked out that most of
our money in previous years has been
spent on maintenance and replacement but
now the council has taken some steps and
been on the front foot in looking to
obtain grant funding for play equipment
such as the 45,000 recently gained for
new equipment at swain Park plus
recently announced another forty five
thousand for play equipment in great
Wakering now the council has got a
number of priorities and those most
certainly include thinking about the
future and perhaps you might expect me
given my background to just remind you
all and the children are our future
they're the next generation and they
deserve the very best that we can do for
them children's healthy lifestyle should
be promoted outdoor play must be
promoted and given opportunity social
spaces for families must be created we
believe that play spaces and playground
equipment can help do these things so
tonight this administration is
announcing a major project to replace an
upgrade play equipment across the
district every ward within the district
will get at least one new piece of play
equipment
potentially designs and concepts could
be ready in March with delivery from
sometime it from delivery with us from
the summer onwards but of course
avoiding the summer holidays when the
equipment is is most most used we're
even going to consider some outdoor gym
equipment for the more mature generation
this is a major initiative from this
administration we've been looking after
our residents money with prudent
financial management and investing into
the future but now the administration is
allocating almost 700,000 pounds for
play and activity equipment with
successful grant funding as I've just
demonstrated and contributions from
parish councils this project could be
worth almost 1 million pounds a huge
investment in our future
we've hora sit down our stress that this
money the funding for this project is
not coming from the council tax the
funding is coming from the new homes
both but new homes bonus and I commend
every member to support it with emotions
that are going to be for you tonight
thank you Thank You council Williams
Thank You chairman Thank You Simon the
funding in the arts to improve our play
space it's very good news excellent news
for the youngsters and community groups
in our district we have also recently
been awarded 90,000 pounds in grants for
play spaces for improvements in Raley
and great working with a relatively low
match from us of only 9,000 pounds so
1,000% bonus further funding bids will
continue hopefully boosting our budget
even more thank you to our officers for
their hard work in in arranging these
bids
we're also budgeting to set aside
approximately 200,000 pounds towards the
much-needed upkeep of our pavilions we
have had interest from parish councils
and local community groups in regards
taking on the responsibility pavilions
in much of the same way as the public
toilets all very good news for our
residents thank you all thank you
presentation by Noemi Lucas will not we
can either take the presentation now or
at the end of any questions if any
member wishes to raise questions to
modify speak after you you thank you and
yes it just had a little more context to
their papers that you've received as you
aware the council is legally obliged to
set a balanced budget each financial
year so we have to match our service
expenditure according to our available
funding the proposed 1920 budget will
enable the council to continue to
deliver against its business plan
priorities whilst facing an
unprecedented period of funding
pressures as you'll be aware the council
was no longer in receipt of any revenue
support grant and it has been given a
one-year reprieve in terms of the
original proposed negative RSG
adjustment of six hundred and thirty
thousand pounds which was expected to be
implemented in 1920
however the projected decrease in
funding levels from 2021 onwards
combined with the new
statue duties we face increased demand
in services and rising inflation still
give rise to project a gap of around 1
million pounds by 2023 to 2024 but
that's obviously pending confirmation of
the council's future funding
arrangements
following the consultations on business
rates and fair funding that the central
government occurring out at the moment
the 1920 the overall pressures on the
budgets total around 700 thousand pounds
and we've managed to identify around
four hundred thousand pounds of
efficiency savings and new income
streams to offset those pressures this
leaves a residual gap of around three
hundred thousand pounds which is
proposed to be met through a 2.9 eighths
and increase on the council tax which
equates to around 13 pence per week for
the average bandy property as has
already been mentioned tonight the
proposed capital program for 1920
includes a significant new investment of
nearly 700,000 pounds on playground
equipment which will be funded from the
final year of the new home spanis grants
in addition the council has set out its
intention to deliver an asset strategy
delivery program and the future capital
program includes the pig figures in the
medium term forecasts which are pending
approval of the outline business case by
fall council on the 19th of February in
addition the papers include the 19:20
capital and treasury management strategy
which have previously been taken to
review committee and this sets out the
parameters and indicators under which
their work on the capital program will
be undertaken the council continues to
maintain a general fund balance of
around 10% of its net revenue budget
which is considered prudent in order to
maintain a contingency for hands porcine
events in addition the council has
maintained earmark reserves but these
remain at the lower end of the
comparable local authorities and
therefore are not considered to be
excessive particularly given the
significant climate the funds financial
uncertainty that the council faces over
the medium term so that's all I was
going to say in relation to the
because at this point by I'm happy to
take any questions that you may have
thank you Thank You chairman
thank you for the presentation it's just
a few concerns I have firstly if I are
specifically mentioned business rate
smoothing and the the reason for I
understand what we're trying to get at
with this which is to to try and have a
reserve there in case we have
particularly caught out by what may
happen with business rates retention but
that then moves you on to reserves
generally and I know you said you it's
in line with other local authorities our
total reserves including earmarks or a
mic around enough to the middle weighs
about eight and a half million pounds I
make it give or take
out of a budget of what was it nine
point nine million I see it's ten point
four six is that total to be raised but
about nine million
spending or so that seems of quite high
to me please we go for a year without
raising any money some of those reserves
I understand the need for others to me
just seem like a general reserve I think
that the business rates yes understand
the levy it seems very high 2.1 million
we've got hard soft infrastructure is
earth which we know is largely used by
the four years by the infrastructure
investment board and that's there at 2.8
million again that seems more like
general reserves to me and it comes
across his general reserves elections i
understand that there might be an
internet and we probably need to hold a
reserve for that legal 304,000 legal
reserve please correct me i'm not aware
that we're facing any legal action if
i'm wrong on it and it needs to be told
to me outside this meeting that would be
fine I'll be happy to accept that to me
we should be providing for things which
are
not necessary certain but maybe
happening I'm not aware that anything
that he's on the horizon or knows okay
if it's something that coffee mentioned
I'd be happy to be corrected outside
this meeting IT reserved 64,000 I
understand there's been problems we've
but we it's just the way the figures
work perhaps but we've taken a hundred
thousand pounds out of the
transformation reserve which to me
agrees to the amount that the new server
room will cost a hundred thousand pound
he might be coerced as he's the same
figure wasn't that reduced in the IT
reserve rather than transformation it
and he just goes on so I'm a bit I'm
uncomfortable is what I'm trying to get
out in raising council tax when we have
reserves which to me seemed quite high
relatively high that's that area the and
if you I just want a little bit
clarification if you come back to be on
the business rate smoothing to see how
much you think of that we might use
year-on-year and it you might you might
be very prudent I don't know I just like
a bit of reassurance around that if
possible I've been just moving on just
generally I'm going through the pages
and perhaps I pick out one of those I
saw earlier three point six nine it's
just an example Cemetery cemeteries we
maintain in France did we were
maintaining cemeteries in house it's
only something I've sorted out you try
foam Marcus Haughton but he wasn't
available sorry I defy you a few times
I'm sorry I did go through just caffeine
if it's not been he's being done in
house why haven't we got any staff
charges to it I don't quite understand
who's doing the work if there's no
costings for for staffing on some of
these things that's an example there are
others others as well
so I'm not sure that Howie cuz I know in
the past has been problems about
costings percentage of staff assigned to
certain things but I'm sure it can't be
that bad we just not doing it at all
they're not just move on to IT computer
services this is just something on a
raise it's in the budget on page three
point four one we've been through a big
transformation over IT we've had a large
budget which we then increased for the
transformation we were reducing the
contract payment which is one of the
reasons for doing it so we'd be paying
less the total the total expenditure for
2019-20
is more than it used to be so the
savings we were supposed to be getting
from this new contract don't seem to
have materialized that the actual single
contract payment itself has decreased
from what it used to be but we seem to
be incurring additional costs for things
that not covered by that contract the
employee costs have gone up from a
hundred and around a hundred forty to
around two hundred eighty
so they've doubled and the and that
would appear to be purely as a result of
the way we're now managing the contract
so I've got concerns that we were given
these figures in the past which says we
will now save X amount on our IT and we
have to move and I understand that it
was good idea to move from there come
with that to some degree might be
question as read how it's done but yes I
could understand the modernization
expect you can't keep old equipment you
know after a lot you have to keep them
updated but the central point this was a
saving and we don't that doesn't seem to
have materialized and that concern goes
through not all but many of these
accounts and that's an example that's
why I do have trouble supporting the
council tax rise and they're just some
that the problems I have with it with
regard I just quickly thank and
councillor Smith for his remarks about
the six hundred fifty seven thousand I
was going to ask how it would be
around the district dog dad at least one
bit of equipment per wold is being sort
of promised God just before Intel that
the 650 7000 works out just over 50,000
pounds per ward and it might be quite
noisy if you'll get closer to that
figure per ward than one piece of
equipment are you understand a skate
park probably sets us back about three
times that right thank you okay thank
you I try and take those points in turn
and so coming back to the overall level
of reserves and balances that the
council holds and we have benchmarked
against other comparable district
councils and we do come out at the the
lower or the very low end of comparable
district councils in terms of their
quantitive and total reserves that we
hold so from that perspective I'm
confident that we're not being over
potent into level of reserves that we
hold as you pointed out yourself they
are held for specific purposes so that
in terms of the major ones so the
pensions reserve that's that's a
particular strategy we've had about
building up so that we when it comes to
try annual valuation we're in a position
to to act accordingly and at that point
in time the hard soft infrastructure
reserve although we've got no plans to
draw that down in 1920 and in terms of
the asset strategy in the medium-term we
have got an intention that we would use
reserves to support the funding around
that program is set out to investment
board so we would be expecting that
balance to diminish over the medium term
and in terms of the business rate
smoothing reserve particularly that is
business rates are by their nature
inherently volatile and we have seen
even this year that we've had our
business rights and collection fund and
deficit has been lower than anticipated
which is what enabled us to put the
money into reserves but at the same time
I forecast for next year is going down
and that the nature of the appeals and
that we face means that we can't predict
with any accuracy what what
what our business rights might be in
future years and coupled with the fair
funding review and the business rates
review more generally we really have
quite a high level of uncertainty about
how much funding we can we are we expect
to receive so I think it is prudent to
hold that level of reserves for business
rate smoothing in terms of the
underlying point about the level of
reserves versus council tax I think as
I've sort of said before if we were to
use reserves as a one-off that would
just be abridged for this financial yeah
it wouldn't enable the underlying
savings to be achieved going forward so
we'd still have to find the same level
of savings going forward from 2021
onwards so it really would just be a
one-off sort of bridge if we were to use
reserves rather than putting up
contracts for this one actually yeah so
I think hopefully that covers off the
points around the reserves and in terms
of their commute computer services
budget I think and there's a danger of
perhaps comparing sort of apples and
pears it's true that the core contract
cost has gone down in terms of any
growth in the budget that's for a new
investment over and above what the core
sort of service delivery aspects veggie
serves so and as your will be aware IT
services while their nature and changed
quite quickly over time and that level
and they and the services that and we
can buy and and change in nature over
time so and it's not it's not quite an
accurate comparison to just compare this
sort of core contract costs with with
the other services that we buy in for IT
and on cement cemeteries I might have to
cross refer but at mine Sonny is the we
haven't really got any direct staffing
costs associated with running those to
say but the actual repairs and
maintenance budget is the aspect as you
say that some gone up and then that's
what we would fund and from the council
but I don't know if Marcus wanted to add
anything further to that
the comment I made about the cemeteries
was more of a comment about costings
rather than about the specific
requirement on even our own cemeteries
today right it's about the way the
costings are done and how we allocate
labor charges okay maybe I misunderstood
your point there yep okay thank you
chairman I'd like just come back on on
on the business of reserves I think with
reserves it's partly to do with your
your viewpoint we are talking about some
considerable figures but we must
remember that we've got many residents
in our district ninety or thousand or so
we've got a good number of employees a
lot of the reserves are earmarked when
we do some serious stuff as a council we
have some serious responsibilities each
year the council is required to provide
national government with figures about
our finances and they're compiled into
tale into various tables and SIP fir
which are the the overseeing body for
council finances the charted Institute
of Public Finance accountants compile
information about districts and their
reserves and as know me as said they're
considered on balance across councils
across the district to be low I prefer
to say that if they're well managed
they're adequate because of course it is
money that's available for for the
residents of the district but we do have
to make sure we really understand the
difference between our revenue and our
capital if we use our capital receipts
to support the revenue that's where we
really start to get into trouble so
although some of the figures are are are
a reasonable size when you take it from
a viewpoint of this council of its
responsibilities of the size of its
population they're adequate
thank you are you happy with that
council hi
well I'm we're so happy but I just
answer your question I'm often very
happy and unhappy yes thank you and
thank you for the answers it was really
and also just question as the increasing
reserves thank you are there any other
questions in that case I'll proceed to
the recommendation now if members are
happy for me to do so I propose taking
all the bullet points with the exception
of the first bullet point on page three
point two five which has to be by a
recorded vote but all the others on
block and unless there's an indication
to the contrary
our members are agreed on all those
bullet points
that case we now move to the first
bullet point on page three point two
five and this is to be approved by a
recorded vote
well all those in favor okay so it's
only work we're going to win out take
the vote
councillor Burton counselor mrs. butcher
counselor canal counselor cut more
councillor Dre
cancel oft Chancellor Gooding Chancellor
Griffin councillor Hazelwood counselor
mrs. high councilor mr. high councilor
Hudson cancel you our new chancellor
Lucas kill councillor mrs lammle
counselor mrs. Macpherson councillor
Marik
counselor mrs. Cullen cancer mrs. Rowe
[Music]
counselor mrs. Shaw counselor mr. Shaw
dismiss counselor Stanley counselor step
to councillor Ward counselor Webb
[Music]
counselor mrs. Weston counselor Williams
that's the Wilson
that is carrot Thank You members that's
the last item on the agenda so I'll call
the meeting to a close as a big
important which others are we talking
about
I took them on block no I took all the
others on block and I said is there to
grieve members and it was agreed council
camel Evan if you'll indulge me I do
agree that you actually agreed that and
I think members agreed just to say I
think this is the last meeting that
Jambo stock will be attending the last
full meeting I like to know it's not
we've got another one all right hold it
in the BIOS but I still got this to
thank John for all the work he's done so
far and look forward to seeing you next
time thank you thank you thank you I'm
now I now call the meeting to close it
evening it's two minutes past days
please be upstanding members as a
Chairman and Managing Director leave the
chamber
you